- Les chambres avec plus
dedeux résidents n'existaient
presque plus dans les CHSLD
du Québec. Puis, le 21 juillet,
cette lettre a eu l'effet
d'un coup de poing.
Comme les listes d'attente
s'allongent pour avoir une place
d'hébergement, le ministère de
la Santé autorise la réouverture
des chambres multiples de CHSLD
jusqu'à quatre usagers
par chambre.
Me GÉHANE KAMEL, coroner
- ... s'assure que les milieux
d'hébergement puissent offrir
des chambres individuelles
aux résidents.
- Moins de trois mois après
que la coroner Géhane Kamel a
remis son rapport sur les décès
survenus au printemps 2020
dans les CHSLD, Québec prend
donc une décision à l'inverse
de ce qu'elle recommandait.
- C'est un recul par rapport
aux conditions des soins.
SOL ZANETTI, porte-parole de QS
pour les aînés
- À la veille des élections,
ils veulent améliorer leurs
chiffres et leurs statistiques
dans les hôpitaux et là,
qu'est-ce qu'ils font? Bien,
ils mettent les aînés du Québec
en d
JOËL ARSENEAU, porte-parole
du PQ en matière de santé
- C'est absolument scandaleux,
en fait, de voir que
le gouvernement peut mettre
à risque la santé encore
une fois des personnes aînées.
- Une accusation exagérée,
selon le cabinet de la ministre
Marguerite Blais, car
les résidents des CHSLD
sont vaccinés et des mesures
de préve d d d d de contrôle
des infections sont en place.
RÉJEAN HÉBERT, professeur,
École de santé publique, UdeM
- La décision actuelle
du gouvernement, je pense,
est la bonne dans le contexte ùu
il y a des milliers de personnes
qui sont en attente,
mais il faut bien réaliser
que ceci résulte de décisions
gouvernementales qui, elles,
ne sont pas appropriées.
- Au CIUSSS de la Capitale-
Nationale par exemple,aaaaa
pour l'instant que deux chambres
multiples qui sont ici,
à l'Hôpital général de Québec.
Mais des familles de résidentset
qu'il n'y en aura pas davantage.
- Je pense que c'est trop lourd.
C'est fatigant comme ça.
- Pour moi, ce n'est pas du tout
bien selon des raisons
sanitaires.
- Québec martèle que
les chambres multiples sont
autorisées seulement si l'espace
le permet. Mais cela n'évacue
pas tous les enjeux pour autant.
- Il risque d'y avoir
plus de contaminations
quand on a plusieurs personnes
dans une même chambre.
BRBRBRBRBRUNET, prés. Conseil
pour la protection des malades
- Et on omet complètement,
et c'est ça qui est triste,
toute la question des autres
infectocococococomiales,
comme le C. difficile.
- La mesure est en vigueur
jusqu'à nouvel ordre, mais
le gouvernement rappelle que
43 maisons des aînés sont enanaD
vétustes et que dans tous
ces projets, il n'y aura que
des chambres individuelles.
Ici Alexandre Duval,
anananananada, Québe